now that we know the basics of tax
brackets let's think a little bit about
what tax deductions are tax deductions
you will often hear that in the u.s. at
least your mortgage interest is tax
deductible or you might get a tax
deduction for doing something that the
government wants you to do or who knows
what it might be but what I want to do
in this video is just focus on how does
that tax deduction translate into a
reduction in of your taxes so let's say
in the last video we had someone who
made one hundred thousand dollars in
income and we saw that that had them
paying based on this very simple tax
code that I set up that had them paying
twenty three thousand dollars in taxes
now let's say that that person had paid
ten thousand dollars in ten thousand
dollars in mortgage interest and
currently that is a tax deduction in the
u.s. so $10,000 they have a ten thousand
dollar tax deduction now my question to
you is if they have this deduction how
much are they going to pay in taxes well
when you just look at the word tax
deduction he's like oh maybe I just
deduct this value from the taxes so if
they were gonna pay twenty three
thousand maybe I just subtract ten
thousand from that and they're gonna pay
thirteen thousand dollars
that is not how what a tax deduction is
what a tax deduction is it really should
be called an income deduction because
what it does is you then deduct the ten
thousand dollars from your income to say
that instead of making a hundred
thousand dollars you made ninety
thousand dollars and then based on this
lowered income this this income that was
reduced by the tax deduction you then
calculate your taxes so in this scenario
how much would the person pay well
they'll pay zero percent on the first
ten thousand that's still true they'll
still pay 20 percent on the next forty
thousand that's still true and then
they're gonna pay thirty percent not on
fifty thousand the fifty thousand that's
above this threshold they're gonna pay
thirty percent on the forty thousand
that is above the threshold so this is
thirty percent of forty thousand because
their income has been reduced by the
deduction at least for tax purposes and
so thirty percent of forty thousand
dollars well that's twelve thousand
dollars that is twelve thousand dollars
and so their total taxes instead of
being twenty three thousand are gonna be
eight thousand plus twelve thousand
or $20,000 in taxes another way to think
about it is this person and $100,000
their highest tax bracket was in the 30%
and that deduction was the even with the
deduction they stayed in that 30%
bracket they went from $100,000 of
income to $90,000 of income so their
income went down by $10,000 their income
went down by $10,000 they had to pay
they had to pay 30% of that 10,000 less
in taxes so their taxes went down by 3
$3,000 so I just want to reinforce a tax
deduction is not a direct deduction from
your taxes it is a deduction from your
income for tax purposes so you don't
save through 10,000 dollars in taxes you
save $3,000 in taxes in this scenario
now what are their scenarios where you
can deduct directly from your taxes yes
they are there are but they're not
called tax deductions those are called
tax credits so if someone gets a tax
credit let's say that this person right
over here above and beyond this tax
deduction they get a tax credit of
$1,000 then this can be directly this
can be directly taken out of the taxes
so the person with the 10,000 the person
making a hundred thousand with a ten
thousand dollar deduction on a one
thousand dollar credit they will then
pay from the deduction we got them to 20
thousand dollars and then because of the
credit we can subtract out another 1000
and then they will pay 19 thousand
dollars in taxes